hello and welcome to the gamespot after
dark podcast live the second live one
and i've just been informed that i've
screwed up a tweet i'm sorry for doing
that just as john luke said like three
uh the thing is like i could leave it
but i look like such a massive boomer if
i leave it
um why can i hear myself oh headphones
there we go i'm gonna delete it because
i don't want to look like a boomer on
the internet there's nothing worse
than looking nothing apparently nothing
yeah it'll be fine but you're listening
and watching the gamespot after dark
podcast this is my second live one i
feel like last week
was good
as their first attempt were you laughing
at it i wasn't laughing i was i just i
still feel bad because you have the car
and i'm like yeah i have the cough i've
got the rona cough here she again you're
mike uh and everyone everyone decided to
sit really close to me they were like
you just sit next to you
but
i would like to once again remind
everyone that um
i have i have beaten the rona
but in many ways the rona has beaten me
because i hit up my doctor and i was
like i've had this cough for a rain on
your doctor what i hit up my dog
i would hit on my doctor ian he's quite
cool ian his name's ian yeah he's a nice
guy why are you first naming your doctor
i call mine jessica my doctor was like
my doctor was super chill he was like
hey what's going on let's chill let's
talk he's like oh you like video games i
like video games too etc etc you're not
dying get out of here that's good
so like he was like yeah you you'll
probably have this cough between one
month and forever and i was like oh okay
sweet thank you nice one
so i'm gonna be coughing a lot
but i promise you i will not be
infecting anyone
which is which is exciting for me and me
but yeah i am joined as always in the
studio
exciting times by jean-luc
hello hi hey
what's up john luke pretty good all
right um i'm extremely we went from i'm
gonna i'm gonna add some consistency you
went from pretty good to all right oh
okay yeah i'm pretty all right
explain
oh that's fine it's thursday um
i i thursday is like always like a low
day for me
like energy wise like i bring it back up
for the podcast but
like i'll tell you right now like you
know in the morning i'm always just like
i'm really like slogging my way through
it you know yeah jordan remain how are
you in the morning in the morning always
tired and usually annoyed because my cat
has been screaming at me for the past
like five minutes to feed her and i'm
like shut the [ __ ] up please wow don't
talk to your cat like that please i
bully her all the time what's your cat's
name benny
fanny penny oh my god
oh my god
um penny can't fanny be a name in
america oh yeah yeah
i have met multiple humans named fanny
and this time i'm like
i would not fly in the uk
uh yeah what's fanny shortfall
vangina
[Laughter]
i
[Laughter]
no like francis
that's franny
oh the actual name yeah
[Laughter]
oh it's meant to be from um
oh it's got a lot feminine name origin
is given diminutives of the french name
francis
francis
and of the name estefan estefany
estefany gwen estefani
and an uncommon spanish version of
stephanie oh okay nice um that was of
course lucy james hello oh uh i'm doing
i'm doing well yeah we're getting into
fanny law i love getting into fantasy no
um
uh yeah hi everyone it's me
i i also have middling feelings about
those days but then again i'm always
tired so
yeah thursdays are a good day for me
generally
but this it's because you know you're
close to friday like i feel the energy
of like yeah one more day
um today might be a good one actually
because
friday this is a weird one friday is
like um
tomorrow like is is the first day before
the fourth of july weekend right oh yeah
so a lot of us are going to be
are going to be like leaving a bit early
tomorrow all right for some um
don't start a video team in every second
week
what the [ __ ] we are here at like
[ __ ] 8pm most days doing live news
your [ __ ] are gone the moment
it hits five o'clock you're like i guess
my premiere pro doesn't work after five
whereas we're here in like early hours
getting up doing nintendo directs at
ridiculous times
that's that's john lucante's uh
let's just say
yeah i i've had to get up for uh
some goddamn like tokyo game show at
like four in the morning also i've
stayed in the office
i've paid my dues i have paid my life
a lot of times it's been like oh we've
all got a recharge day and all of
editoria is like we can't take those
days because we've got stuff to do but
we were videos like
yeah we're going for a we're going for
the entire
don't ever talk [ __ ] about anything
when did i talk to you about editorials
i was talking to [ __ ] about you
that's fair enough that's fair enough um
but friday we're probably all going to
be pissing off
a little bit yeah i was going to go work
from jen and greg
yeah i mean that's fine i've already
told everyone that i manage and people
who also i don't manage but i do oversee
that they are expected to leave early
tomorrow excellent so it's like it's
like the friday feeling is happening
today i'm like going away from tomorrow
so i'm like
i won't be able to have my usual friday
chicken wings which means i could
technically have them on thursday
tonight today is thursday do it which
means are you streaming today i am i'll
go straight in the car get chicken wings
and watch lucy's stream
that could be a good first day that's a
nice thing yeah
even though you don't like the quarry
yeah but i want to see i want to see you
play through the remainder of the quarry
and see that's the thing i want to see
whether you do the thing where you're
like i like this or if you do the thing
where you're like i don't like this but
i'm just going to be very positive
[Music]
you'll notice in those so in those cases
i'm just like yeah not saying much
so when we whenever we beat a game like
the quarry or like a like a telltale
game georgia will do this thing where
she immediately goes and watches like
all of her favorite youtubers and
streamers like play through that game
yeah and she just judges the [ __ ] out of
them so she doesn't like
that's me watching
uh
they got they got ryan and ryan uh
killed jacob like super early he like
[ __ ] up so bad i mean she'll just like
tell me all this [ __ ]
i was by the end of that game i was
trying to kill everyone oh i mean
there's a character that i was actively
trying to
no no i'm not gonna spoil but i
absolutely i hated her so much that
there was a bit where you i could have
saved her and both decisions could have
i assume like fended off whatever would
happen and i just put my controller down
i was like do you know what the funny
thing is die she's actually the best
character shut up no wait wait everyone
else won the
is that the character that you should
say the name of uh i think it's i mean
like i think she's dead in your game i
finished it you finished i finished it
so like it's for anyone and like anyone
she could be kept alive or so it's not
really a spoiler but what is her name
again um
emma oh emma okay okay emma so she's
annoying as [ __ ] and then in that scene
if you do everything right you realize
she's incredibly competent
like she's just like
bear spray [ __ ] punch closed door
down thing and she's like absolutely
like destroying this monster constantly
and i was like i was i was gonna kill
her in that scene and then i did some of
the qts and i was like okay she's
annoying but she's coming she's proved
herself everyone else she deserves to
live everyone else is just like a
downslide for the rest of the game
everyone gets [ __ ] and [ __ ] she
was such a [ __ ]
she's such a [ __ ] but like at least
she's smart and she knows what she's
doing every single day from this point
on like for me i was like
i don't understand any of you like
you're all behaving like absolute
lunatics i want all of you to die
especially ryan yes oh dude i hate you
he gets
worse and worse he does by the end of
the game i was like
i was convinced that he's in on
everything because i was like
i think what summed up like my feelings
on ryan is like there's a
scene where ryan and another character
like have to interact with each other
for the first time
and there's like this extended scene and
every line of dialogue between those two
characters is like the worst dialogue
ever and i was like understand if ryan
like the the actor who plays ryan and
normally i don't like to [ __ ] i don't
know who that is he's in detective
people never seen it he's in uh
and he's done a bunch of different
things and so like in that scene i was
like wow and and i'm sitting there being
like it's just like their attempt to do
like quippy writing just awful but then
the
scene
goes to dylan and kaitlyn in a scene
together and they're also being quippy a
thousand times more likeable though yeah
so it's just like i
and i feel bad i feel bad for the actor
because i i don't want it to be his
fault i don't know if it is his fault
but
something about the way he's looking at
borders
as [ __ ] he like his writing is genuinely
like he's written in a way where
they use him to push
past plot holes like constantly the
amount of plot holes that appear where
he's just like actively like ignoring
them it's a cool way to that wouldn't
happen what are you doing why are you
why are you behaving like this he's and
then
there's that one other character who
shows up later who i i was my favorite
character for like for five minutes for
like five minutes or like this like no
for that whole challenge there's one
chapter where you're like she's good and
then the second she has to interact with
the rest of them they're all bad yeah
actually it's like ryan's like badness
like infected her there is one scene
where um
she makes a facial expression that is
just a perfect recreation of lucy's face
what there
is scene where
she's like i don't know if you ever get
but like
there's a moment lucy where she's going
to be in a bathtub
don't hold your breath
oh i think i didn't get that scene i
didn't do this i didn't do that
don't
she does the the like
the lucy james looking for a lip from
the distance like a full extended neck
and then like doing the doing the like
the
oh i thought white people thin lips face
that and i looked at it and you can see
me on the stream i just laughing oh i
was gonna say if there's a clip of it
there is a clip of it i can find
don't you okay
vamp for me for a minute um
but like jean-luc you've played it now
that's that's the top of what you're
kind of like um what you've been playing
yeah what did you think about it i did
end up actually enjoying it quite a bit
like despite my issues with it because i
agree like i think everything we said is
like on point i was really frustrated
with ryan i it's it's got a lot of weird
inconsistencies but i also think
i just still had like a really fun time
with it i think it has like a lot of
like very fun characters like dylan's
great love dylan uh caitlyn's great
mostly because it's just brenda's song
and brenda's song's great i would say
did you play by yourself or did you play
it uh yeah i played it with george maybe
that could have possible
like just making fun of the people with
someone else there yeah yeah and then
her like judging me when i like [ __ ] up
horribly and get someone killed
uh which was fun um i did i did
i did [ __ ] up the ending really bad
oh no
it doesn't
i've seen that too many times
i don't know if you want to drop it in
twitch check the camera you can see it
like oh you totally good
i mean we should we'll make sure to drop
it in the exact podcast feed yeah
oh my god
she looks like a turtle
i felt really bad today because um
[Music]
i dropped in we have like a giant bomb
discord
like a
and i dropped in i quit and then i
dropped in um a screenshot of a comment
someone had left but it took so long to
upload that jan was like what the hell
but it was because someone tweeted me in
response to um i was on game mass
mornings yesterday and
someone just replied to the clip that we
posted with
uh lucy you've got such a long neck
you're like a giraffe
and i was like
oh
but now i've got now material i'll link
in the in the chat for twitch oh
excellent
and yeah we'll make sure it's on the
podcast yeah we'll make sure to link
that on podcast as well but yeah god
damn
carry on what would you make of it i
enjoyed it i had a good time with it i
mean you know it's
like like we were saying kind of a lot
inconsistencies but i i think it just it
does enough well that i like i had a fun
ride with it you know um it helps that i
did get
like the quote like
good good ending i guess like so like
jacob uh jacob why is he jacob seems
jake his name is jacob isn't it what is
jacob yeah but i don't know i have never
called him
jacob before i don't know like maybe
you're talking about the no i'm talking
about jake decker
oh jacob mccoy no jacob the character in
the game no no i'm talking about jake
decker
who i call jacob for some reason i'm so
confused
as a test to see if he listens to this
because he's not on the show today can
we all just refer to him as jake jacob
jacob
jacob
so uh jacob last week was talking about
how he had the
like his ending just didn't make sense
and felt like it was missing scenes
having beaten that game i know exactly
what he's talking about because if
there's
like i want to say like what like one or
two specific characters were like you
could have made a choice very early on
that would like completely just negate
getting that ending where you
essentially like
kind of reveal like the the missing
pieces
of like the story
and
so i was like yeah
that would really suck to not get that
but i also kind of i don't know in
theory i like that they kind of do that
like i think that's i think that's kind
of interesting but i also didn't
experience that crushing something
disappointing yeah i i could completely
feel differently i had those moments
where the game was cut into
between different things but it was it
was clear that they had been removed
because of the way the game was played
by me so it would like cut and then
nothing would happen
i would have that too right where it's
like fade in characters are like hey
how's it going like pretty good fades
out and you're like yeah what something
should have happened here this was meant
to be a scene it might be a spoiler at
the end of the game it fully does there
here's a picture of the character's face
a bit of text well what happens no it
does stop it it does does it like that i
got that for every single character and
like the way my game concluded i was
like
that was [ __ ] like it was i want my time
back like it was awful it was like the
way it concluded was
it put me in a decision-making moment
where the only way i made the decision
in a split second because it was the
only
reasonable thing to do sure like the old
there's they're like oh you could do
this or you could try this and you're
like
why would i ever do that like that's
insane like you've not made a good
compelling case for this other thing so
like i immediately was like press this
button and then it just cuts to end of
game and it's like and pucci went back
to his planet and i was like okay he did
that it did that for me too and i'll
admit like i think it could use like a
it needed like a little bit more at the
end right
at the end of mine no one talks to each
other and it's like damn dude that
sucked i'm glad we made it out yeah
nothing i can't wait for someone to
suggest the quarry makes top 10 of the
year to 10 no it's not it's
the other thing i don't like about it
and it's become more and more present is
all the environments are empty and like
you got you're not doing anything in
them yeah i mean i just i just walk from
one to another and then i usually ask
chat like find out
there's nothing there though like most
in most of the room you go into a room
it's a big barn and it's just like
there's a barn there's nothing yeah i
like i do the thing where i like walk
around everything right and i'm always
like why did i do that there's clearly
nothing here like the only thing that i
need to do is move from these
environments at which point i'm just
like annoyed by the fact that i'm
basically moving from point to point in
the most like
boring way possible i mean part of me
wishes at some points where it's like um
you can play that movie mode or whatever
oh sure that seems like the way to play
yeah did you um did you stay through the
credits did you listen to the credits
one of the worst end quotes ever
at the beginning of the game they
present you with this idea where like
hey if you we need to collect evidence
because no one's going to believe this
so they start collecting evidence yeah
no one's going to believe us even though
we have [ __ ]
phones where everyone's
phone is on 10 and last for 10 hours and
i'm like how are you doing this
everyone's like filming [ __ ] and they're
taking pictures i'm like what are your
batteries what are your phones yeah they
do establish the battery thing right
right everything comes out
of their phones
all of their phones lost the entire game
you are right what are you talking about
they do drop that but like i was like
okay so at some point there's gonna be a
scene where we like try and convince a
cop or something like that what's going
on
all of that is so that at the end of the
game there's a couple of really [ __ ]
annoying characters that are introduced
and they're podcasters for that podcast
that whatever his name is listening to
and they do a full podcast episode about
what happened at the quarry where they
talk through the evidence and it is the
most annoying thing i have ever seen
somebody like sends them a box with all
the evidence you connected yeah and then
they go through it and it's like
convincing the other person like that
happens i liked it i thought it was
funny
it's like scripted but they're like
trying to make it sound natural like a
podcast but it's clearly scripted
and it goes on for a while it goes on
too long and there were definitely like
weird dips where you're like okay
through this but i liked the idea a lot
and i i was like you know what that's
clever and fun
i mean it just did not work for me
because i was trying to skip it i was
like please let's go and it would not
let you skip and afford it i feel like
this game is the perfect example of just
like
how like your video game
the slight differences in your
experience can like dramatically alter
the way you feel about a game yeah well
you know because it's just like you can
have such a wildly different experience
just depending on
your choices or how you happen to feel
about just like yeah the certain way
like your acting is because it's like
i don't know it's really hard to like
write a coherent story right like to
like write like a coherent movie yeah
just like start to finish even a movie
as like simple as this would be
difficult they have to write like a good
version of this story and then they have
to write 20 like not as good versions of
this story with scenes missing the thing
is like it's like
but to make them all try and be good
must be in so incredibly i have thought
my i think they did it with until dawn
like until dawn i think they nailed it
like yes and no
i think the difference is is that
in this game i think they try to take a
risk by making it have more variations
than until dawn and i think that's what
messes it up because until dawn when you
go back and you play through multiple
times you kind of realize that there are
some characters that just straight up
have plot armor yeah and like there is
like youtube videos of people who are
like i think there's a scene where um
it's like mike and he's running away you
can fail every single quick time event
and nothing happens to him at all i kind
of like prefer that than
having like massive chunks of of a story
removed because of the absence of a
character i know it's like in theory
like at the end of the day like
characterization kind of like character
stuff flaws that you can look at
you can then like
kind of hand wave away if it all comes
together in an interesting way whereas
this with this game like you can kill
off a character and the sacrifice you're
making is the end story is not going to
be as compelling yes what happened to me
because i was like
and like surprisingly only one
character in mind died so like everyone
was there except for one person and the
story was still not good and i was like
i don't i don't understand what's going
on here right because
in theory the ideal thing would be
something like until dawn but they would
do a better job of hiding the plot armor
that's um character right oh my god it
did this thing that drove me
wild
so mad there's a moment where
you're fighting a monster and you have a
shotgun yeah okay and the monster is
like coming towards you and like it's
like okay you gotta pick the perfect
moment earlier in in the game what's her
name
kristen [ __ ] caitlyn caitlin caitlyn is
like a song i'm awesome at shooting oh
yeah they just don't give her the gun
they don't give her a gun for ages
because she's like i'm awesome at
shooting and then she's just like gun
shy for the rest of the
game she's not like i'm good at shooting
she's like watch me shoot all this [ __ ]
that didn't happen to me she actually
got a gun very early in my playthrough
okay she did lose it like she made she
goes yeah that's the thing she gets
robbed almost instantly and you're like
what is wrong with you um uh but like
she makes big pains she goes to big
planes to say this shotgun has got like
a a weird spread so make sure you know
you're basically shooting at the right
moment effectively so like the monster
is about to attack me right
i shot it i shut it once and it kind of
missed so i was like okay i need to wait
for the right moment yeah so it does the
thing where it edges closer and i was
like okay biting my time so i can get it
into the right shooting distance as all
shotguns do
moves closer still very far away from me
like end of the table far away from me
the game just cuts to killing me ah
from the other side of the room i'm like
what
did you have the red
danger it just was like it was like
super far away from me i was like i'm
gonna let us take one more step closer
so i can get all the all those bug shots
in there into this one enemy and it'll
be perfect and i was aiming as well like
i was just waiting for my moment and it
just like cut to me being killed and i
was like okay well yeah that sucks um
which i found really annoying yeah
yeah i i think it's got a bunch of like
weird little quirks like that that keep
it from being
as good as it could be but
i don't know for whatever reason it's
just like
the vibe of it all just like worked for
me and i just like still had a campy
horror yeah yeah i can't be horrible
you know i still think until dawn's the
better game overall for sure um oh one
thing i hated about it was i thought the
music choices were [ __ ] awful like
there's the one at the beginning the
ariana grande
how much did they spend it if they get
an ariana grande well the ariana grande
one was fine i was like oh okay like
kind of setting the tone wait till you
get to the ending theme no
is it worse than this girl is on fire um
that one was actually funny though well
good for you because i didn't get it
yeah that's a good joke my game just
went silent oh really yeah so they they
were like we finished the game they were
all laughing and i was just like
what it's
there's like two tracks that play in
like kind of like the eighth and ninth
chapter at the end that was just so
they're being like modern or
no they're going for some like
twangy indie kind of thing it was the
tone of it was so bad
i feel like also like
they really needed someone to
to do like a cringe check on the entire
script sure i i
offer myself a massive i offer my
services any game developer if you want
a cringe check on your script just let
me know and i'll tell you whether it's
cringe or not because the amount of
times i've been like
a boomer wrote that 100 of you wrote
that pretty much every line of dialogue
pretty much every line of dialogue is
like
no one cringe check this at all but
again like dylan like i thought dylan as
an example like mate like every time he
talked it was like yeah it worked dylan
dylan is my friend i think dylan's
actually also um
character jacob not podfather jacob is
my favorite because he's a himbo he's
good abby was my favorite i liked jacob
he does kind of disappear in the
second half my sweet boy he comes back
he comes back but i i i was missing him
as well yeah yeah i was just like i
kinda was he comes back for like no
reason
but i do think that's one thing i kind
of give the quarry over until dawn is uh
as much as i like hated some of the
characters in the quarry there are some
characters that i really got attached to
i can't really
i don't know if i really cared about any
of the characters in until dawn like
thinking back oh yeah i mean like i i
found
them
to be archetypal in a way that made
sense for that genre like you don't
really care about like sydney in in
scream do you really yeah that's what i
got for until dawn like these are like
scream characters
until don is very much trying to wink
wink nudge nudge yeah everyone's
disposable you might have your faves
pick them let's go whereas this game
like they want to invest in these
characters and they're all unlikable
like almost all of them gillen's dylan's
good um abby's good but like she's she's
likeable because she's very innocent and
sweet um like dylan is like he's the
he's the kind of like charismatic kind
of like kind of weird person although he
has some moms where you're like why are
you being a creep man that's very
strange
why are you doing it yeah and then uh
what's her name brenda song's character
is like
assistant she's like one minute she's
like oh yeah i'm badass i'm gonna do all
this stuff next minute she's like
i've lost my gun what do you mean to be
fair i identify with that a lot but
there's a bit where she's like we're
gonna do this
and then someone's like great let's
begin this two-mile walker she's like
two miles
what are you talking about a minute ago
you're like we have to save everyone and
now you're like worried about a slight
walk it's like 20 minutes max calm down
i relate i
oh
but i can like i can like retweet it
with like this is lucy james
um and that'll be fine what else have
you been playing john luke i've been
playing more neon white although i don't
really have much to say other than like
you know
white school uh yeah it's like it's
still good um i definitely i think i've
felt more of the cringiness and the
dialogue the further i've gotten in that
you guys were talking about like i at
the beginning i was like oh yeah like i
don't mind the dialogue and now i'm like
no okay the more i'm going into this
spit it's a bit it's a bit much it's a
bit it's a bit onliney i'm i honestly
i'm i'm
scrolling through i finally i remapped
my my i rebound my keys
to to get maximum like card shuffling
like a speed runner yeah i put that on
on the wheel so i'm not like trying to
faff around but yeah the the dialogue
stuff i'm i'm yeah i'm just like
yeah i'm like
i'm a little intrigued in the narrative
aspect of like i kind of want to know
where it's going and sort of like oh
what's like the twists but yeah some of
the character writing i'm like it's a
little unfortunate it doesn't like ruin
the fact that like it's still like a
great game
wise but it's one of those things it's
like but if it was a great game gameplay
wise and the story was like
really good then it would be like game
of the year material yeah easily yeah i
mean it still is like definitely going
to be my top 10 100 i think the
it's more egregious because of the pace
of the actual game that's so quick
really yanks you out yeah there's
whiplash when you suddenly cut to like a
solid five minutes of like visual novel
where nothing interesting is happening
oh i'll go to this bar yeah let's go
over this thing but like i feel like
it's got an interesting concept more
than it has execution
also a game that could have done with a
cringe check on that script oh yeah yeah
massively again yeah uh what's his name
ben ben esposito if you know cringe
check let me know i'll take a look at
your script is that the name of this
episode
i might open a like an actual like um
service no you cannot do more things you
are already doing too many things
hit detection the game consulting yeah
cringe check cringe cringe check i will
check your script for any cringe and and
like make sure that the the kids aren't
going to be like look at these [ __ ]
weirdos
i would love for there to be a game one
day that i'm playing where in the
credits it just says
if you're a video game developer out
there and you want a cringe check i'll
do it for free
i'll do you no 10.
corey barlog
i'm
ready i will do a cringe check for free
um and you can you know i'm an authority
because i've never posted cringe so
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna go through
it right now you can there's a lot of
questionable content on there but none
of it's cringe
none of it's cringe
the rest of the episode lucy's just
silent and she's just slowly scrolling
i'm gonna genuinely look into making a
company called cringe
i'd hire you
great thank you i'll i'll i'll get to if
you don't think i can whoop every
american president's ass on follow me
yeah everyone keeps telling me that taft
would would beat me that's not happening
every [ __ ] president is washed i
would kill firstly if those presidents
were moved to this time and age to fight
me they would die immediately because
their their like immune systems are not
built for modern day was it was it
i mean neither neither are ours i would
cough on all presents and they would all
die because they're just not built for
it i mean there was the one president
who got shot in the during a speech and
he's the one and that's just an
indictment of whoever tried to
assassinate him being really bad shot
okay fair enough i mean like
that was me i'd be like nailing that
last time
this podcast is
[Laughter]
blacklisted
i'm still i'm still looking for
christmas there's no cringe i'm telling
you this is one no this is cringe corner
cringe corner i'm in cringe corner uh
well some that isn't cringe that i've
been watching it's very good i know if
you've you've all been watching it uh
our flag means death oh i haven't saw it
yeah my partner just showed that to me
we benched through all ten episodes okay
we're two episodes left okay dude that's
a really good show
so for those who don't know it is about
um
a man named steve bonnet who is the
gentleman pirate
and he is like he is the annoying guy
that edward meets at the beginning of
black flag
steve on it yes so okay so that's the
thing the obama what's going on steve
bonnett the annoying dude who saves
edward at the beginning of black flag is
the protagonist so that was the thing i
did not realize until halfway through
isn't that real he was a real person
because i was like going through and i'm
like assassin's creed pretty much
everyone but the protagonist is like a
real person i forgot about
that thing but i mean i mean i was like
watching this being like oh it's a fun
pirate show and this man you know they
got a couple things like blackbeard and
then they're like no steve bonnett was a
real man who in like the 1700s had a
midlife crisis and left his family to go
become a pirate and it was a miserable
failure at it and it was like what just
like
yeah
i mean
the only part that's fictional is that
he definitely did not um like fall in
love with blackbeard that i mean that
didn't happen
no no no they apparently did interact oh
okay okay but but it's in what happened
was blackbeard basically like coerced
him into like give me your ship so that
i can add it to my fleet and then he
used it to like win this really big
battle but who's to say that's not just
like someone who admired blackbeard
trying to rewrite the history around him
and be like maybe it was a homophobe who
wrote like black beard's history maybe
who knows yeah maybe blackbeard was
really like yeah maybe blackbeard was a
tough gtf
uh it's really funny though it like yeah
it's just a
top tier comedy talk to your actors in
it uh
it's like uh take a white td is like
blackbeard is like um solid choice
amazing
rhys darby is uh steve bonnet is so good
um leslie jones
isn't it
yes um
she's fantastic just every everyone and
then there's like i say that she also is
a real person in history right i cannot
remember that spanish jackie yeah
spanish jackie
i think that's something is she also a
real person spanish jackie yeah that's
what i want to say
that i think so
there is no was spanish jackie a real
person
more of that
that's john's place
oh my god because calico jack is also
calico jack's real person another
annoying character from black flag they
apparently they i guess he was
technically not alive
or like he wasn't pirating at the same
time blackbeard was like yeah
they kind of tweaked that one also he's
played by will arnett extremely funny
yes which is like such a strange choice
for calico jack but he does a really
good job
he does such a good job and like the
direction they take that plot line is so
funny it's oh it's yes like top tier
cast yes spanish jackie
seems likely based on jacques
de la haye a legendary figure from
modern day haiti who took over the
caribbean island of tortuga and made it
into a free booth republic that comes
from screenrent.com which put that
little bit of information
four paragraphs into that
yes okay
just [ __ ]
relax as someone
that's one paragraph away from the
ending of the article okay
i know it is it might have written an
article like that in chris and tammy i
would like i don't know
you have to make some sacrifices for seo
but this is bad okay the news pyramid
says you get the pertinent information
in the first two paragraphs
unbelievable great show extremely gay uh
great okay great non-binary
representation with uh jim jim's a
really good character
on my list i need to finish the
leftovers and then yeah you know we
should watch if you like that
pirates one piece easy okay is it gay
another gay pirates
okay cool all right
uh
excellent
mean the one difference is that like
our flag means death is 10 10 episodes
25 minute episodes not uh you know
a billion or whatever i saw um
lisa
from twitch uh
lisa allen or wisa allen
uh she
did a a subathon and like the highest
tier if she reached it she'd have to
start
one chapter a week yeah she'll be done
she won't fit
i'm afraid she will
i think at this point if you're starting
one piece in 2022 you're dead before you
finish seeing the end oh absolutely yeah
100
um i watched there was a time where i
watched one piece maybe for about four
hours a day yeah you watched a lot i
watched a lot of one piece um and i'm
still not up to date
at one point i was trying to get up to
date by watching and reading at the same
time oh my god and also i was working at
london underground so i had a lot of
time on my hands okay i was like between
my shifts like just sitting there
reading reading good could not make it
could not make it there are
that thing's got more fillers the
average filler arc for for uh a number
of filler episodes for one piece is
longer than most actual series from
beginning to end which is wild
yeah i mean uh i
stone who watched a lot of naruto i mean
i'll i i'm very familiar with just an
obscene amount of failure but i'm sure
i'm sure one piece handily beats it yeah
um louie in the chat says love you only
flexing the no caffeine sprite
um yeah disgusting i mean i just like i
like a nice light crisp you know it's
like it's not got too much
uh
it's not overpowering on the on the
sugar in the but you know it's like
i don't know the sprite should be
painful man it's refreshing no
mcdonald's part is the way to go most
painful sprite on the market which is
why it's the best one
um
jordan what you been up to
i say i was talking to john luke about
this before we started i'm like i
haven't had much opportunities to
actually
do any like
new stuff play anything new watch
anything new because i
showed my
partner the first episode of uh misfits
and magic which is a dimension 20 d d
show where they like just destroyed uh
harry potter for like four episodes
while playing d d
and they loved it and so we're watching
more dimension 20 shows and so i've just
been watching
re-watching like dnd shows and just
showing like oh this is the unsleeping
city this is fantasy high this is a
crown of candy and she's just gobbling
it up and loving it and now she's like
yeah and now she's like excuse me i
would i would i would love to play dnd
and i'm like well this was not the
outcome that i had anticipated but here
we are really playing the long day
as your manager jordan i forbid you from
using the word gobble again
what's wrong with goblins just don't say
god in the uk maybe is it a uk thing i
don't know it's just
i've said two words today that you both
uk people what was the other one fanny
fanny and gobbling well i didn't
actually say
[Laughter]
i will be playing a bunch of new stuff
or after hollow night uh this weekend
just because as i was leaving the
apartment to
come here to work today
ran into the ups guy who had my steam
deck package
about to
just load up on a bunch of steam games
onto the steam deck starting with hollow
knight and then we'll see where it runs
right about on it how would you know i
played it before i deleted it almost
immediately yeah
he i remember when he blackmailed me
i i paused between the two halves
well last week i did pre-order my steam
deck and every day i'm like
where's the email decks out for the lads
you're probably not going to get that
email for all no i know
i don't know
there's a valve just gobbling up those
orders
so you can use it i can use it yeah that
doesn't seem fair and there's a lot of
things about left arm
um one piece try line says one piece has
86 weapons of episodes of filler naruto
has 350. is that accurate anime boys
i mean i wouldn't know that when i when
i watched 150 okay i don't think it has
350 yeah
[ __ ] ton no no because
the original run of naruto
like where
the actual manga like ends and then they
were like all right well we gotta wait
for a while before we actually start
adapting shippuden so they just have
like 150 episodes of [ __ ] filler and
i watched all of it because i was sick
and i was like i was like like literally
sick or something no like mine i was
like stuck at home for like three days
and i was like i'll just binge watch
naruto got to the end of it realized
that it was all filler and it was like i
just wasted three days of my life that
says a lot though because like you can
get through a decent chunk of naruto
filler and not realize it's filler it's
not good episodes no because every other
problem with was like
probably one hey i think maybe this
person might know where sasuke is and
then like nothing happens and there is
that one episode where lee is just
eating curry for a really long time i
mean that one sounds like that one which
is great sure
yeah you gave us the lead kind of like
springtime review spin off but the
problem with one piece filler is the
moment it starts you're like this is
villa i know immediately this is filler
that whole like sky pier arc with god
enel which happens at the start like
it's i remember watching that being like
this is some of the worst [ __ ] i've ever
seen in my life what's going on
i'm not even convinced you're talking
about anything really
yeah we just made that all up yeah but
don't look at it there's something wrong
with a good ox in one piece
sure very very good yeah i'll just take
your word for it yeah i'm not gonna
skype
i don't have enough years left in life
is it
it's the first time yeah it's the first
time you meet god i know i don't think
it's called skype yeah it's called like
something else it might be canon it
sucks either way
um
but
yeah anything else jordan
uh no no that's it that's it good
um lucy what you been up to
uh so uh playing the quarry which we
talked about playing neon white which
we've talked about
oh i did finally
yeah oh yeah oh yeah that's why that's
the main meal of my section
this is just the appetizer
i can tell i'm hungry
i'm hungry no um so i was around
at uh max and jen's on monday and max
just got a um a quest two and i got to
play some of resident evil 4 on the
quest too and holy [ __ ] you played you
played a vr game why are you playing
why'd you be like i just experienced the
questions
i am but also
um i didn't want to have to pay 40
dollars for the game yeah i didn't have
to pay for it in case like it was bad if
i pulled that game twice
i'm pretty sure i've won that game like
yeah
me twice like i i just purchased it on
on the browser and i was like cool and i
went to it and i was like no you don't
own this so i had to purchase it again
um well that's the thing can i still buy
um games now that i have
side loaded beat saber yeah you can okay
that's fine um no as i played it and i
didn't realize i know kurt did the
review of it last year but that was six
months ago and i have no memory anymore
um but just like
getting the shotgun over my shoulder and
reloading yeah it was really cool
wielding and you could have the knife in
one hand and the gun in the other
i i had already i mean we only played a
little bit
i only played a little bit rather
because um then jen and i watched
episodes of uh
with trixie and katja on the big tv oh
oh okay yeah i think how do you how do
you say uh yeah no like that like that's
how it is
saying they finally got their life
together which is good that means they
were transitioned from listening on
podcasts to listening live
oh yeah so welcome welcome to the
following see your work last week and i
told everyone to get their life together
and listen
here we go hey love to see it it's
probably me welcome
um
so resonate before very good um i think
i'm gonna buy that and play this weekend
i'm doing that as well currently yeah i
was playing resident evil i'm going for
it slowly because um well i started
playing it while i had covered which is
a bad idea what are you doing um you
played a vr game
i was like what how how how can i make
this so much worse
and i was like oh i started resonating
before maybe i should go back to it i
hope you just like dipped that entire
headset and just like disinfected yeah
just like a bottle of disinfectant
he's like no it's my headset
i mean
you're gonna like forget about it in
like six months like someone's gonna
come over and you're gonna hand it to
them i don't think you know how a viral
virus would work
i don't think virus is just like
standing at the doorway waiting for
people
soon
but i got into uh the the another
overwatch beta
um
so i got to play a little bit of jank
queen i can't say her name properly i
have to say with the australian accent
the janka queen uh i like her a lot
she's wildly overpowered at the moment
which is a lot of fun um but her move
sets really good she's really
interesting really fun for overwatch i
feel like i've talked a lot about
overwatch too at this point you're
playing on pc again are you using this
beta to play
but when i was playing when i tried to
play the console version because i got
my code through the uk
um or at least i i when i applied for
the code they said which region i was
like well my playstation account is
british um
i haven't i have a uk code and when i
tried to play
nothing happened well i believe that's
still a thing that happened well i think
it was just because it was time zones
and like no one was really awake but i
was having issues on playstation and i
don't think that's the case anymore i
think it was just my weird
thing but uh i'm going to try playing
this weekend play more of watch to maybe
tonight after stream but i
i'm really struggling to go back to
regular overwatch overwatch one just
because two is so much cleaner
like the audio work is like and i i
didn't really pick this up until i
played it like the last time but the
audio work is really good when you're
playing as anna which for some reason
i've been playing a lot of zana recently
but like just her her sniper rifle has a
lot of weight to it now and has a lot of
like
like really sounds
no i've seen that because i don't know
what i did i don't know why i did
like me when it
like really trying to get hurt
sometimes you've got to breathe you know
squeeze it out
um
it happens
how do we get here
what have i done what have i done
uh but no i um
yeah i've been playing a bunch of that
really enjoying it
it's overwatch i like joker queen i
haven't really formulated a lot of
thoughts on it since like the last time
we played because i only really played a
few rounds but it's i don't know i'm
excited i played some with andy cortez
from kind of funny the nitro rifle rifle
um
the other day and uh i was
i was like i'm gonna learn how to play
genji wow so i started playing genji let
me tell you
i'm not a good genji
i was getting not against you man i had
a i had a platinum genji player in my
chat for on twitch
teaching me as i was doing it and i was
like
i don't think i like this character he's
very very like he doesn't feel good like
you even when i hit people with my
shurikens i'm like
that did not feel good
i took off one pixel of health um and
then like i was playing i did like three
rounds or three games with genji and
then it was like um i was playing flex
and then it put me in tank and i was
like i'm gonna play zarya and i switched
to zarya and everyone else on the team
was like god damn what's going on
um but yeah i might go back to i'm gonna
i want to pick up a new character um and
and like
soldiers to i don't know i'm gonna play
a lot of ash actually and i think she's
so i think she's fun yeah i
don't know do you think you could go to
hanzo i just don't like characters that
us
like have not they die easily that they
don't have a lot of i don't like squishy
characters very much like genji and
hanzo are very squishy yeah um i usually
play like ryan or zarya obviously but i
want to pick up a dps character that i
feel good about so uh i mean creed
suggests uh sojourn
yeah is another one that i could try
she's a little squishy but she's got a
lot more mobility she's so fast yeah
she's fast she's got this she's fast as
[ __ ] boy exactly
um so i might try that but
genji i think is just not my style where
it's like um poking people and like just
being very vertical um and like i just
want to get in there and be like
annoying um well i mean new sombra is
very annoying
yeah i do like sombra and maybe that's a
character i can get they change sombra i
have not played as or with assam
i think hacking is just quicker and like
okay all that kind of stuff she's just
more disruptive basically yeah i do like
being annoying and like stealthy so
maybe her but
yeah
she's it's fun the game's fun i'm
excited for more um
i'm probably going to be playing some
maybe today as well um but
the bait is out there you can't get in
unless you buy that weird pack
which is like 30 or you get blessed by
the the blessed gods if you're in the
previous beta are you still on this yeah
so we
get yeah for us we were in the alpha so
we got converted to the debater cool
that's available now maybe i'll try more
i think i need to play with like people
like i just tried playing it by myself
for like a minute and was like join us
on pc sure
love that and console
um yeah anything else in overwatch oh
no i was a oh i did actually watch the
new beavis and butthead movie any good
was it good it was surprisingly good and
i have never seen any beavers in butt
head before um oh i wonder how it is if
it if it's good if you have seen a lot
of somebody uh the people we were with
like they enjoyed it um did cornhole
appear he needs tp for his bunghole
guy with a with his shirt over his head
i am cornholio
and he tipped me for my bungalow i
believe he did no that was really good
there was a there was a point where i i
did leave to go outside
um because i was with my friends and
they had their kid and i she wanted to
look outside so i took her out and i was
like look here's a tree he's good let's
get away from the guy who's screaming
and he needs tp for his buttonhole but
like um no it was really good i
really enjoyed it despite not having
someone in chat are you threatening me
which is a quote from the and then
mubarak and robot was like no deleted
[Music]
we have no control over moobot uh but no
i really enjoyed it i um had no idea
what to expect because bieber's in
behead has completely passed me by i've
only ever seen it referenced in other
things but i thought it was very funny
yeah that's good um i was drunk when i
watched it i mean that's it's like half
of the course yeah slightly inebriated
is the best way to watch be with some
butt head but i i've got a soft spot
[ __ ] on audio
it's a fun character i am cornelia
i did a lot of that in my teenage years
just to annoy people
um tp for my bun hole is like just a
great quote that you can use um that you
can use that you can use tell your
friends i need for my bunghole
um anything else
no
you sound so sad wow
i i just i feel like
i just haven't done a lot but then i
remembered i went on holiday so yeah
it happens it happens we're in the
quieter period of game releases season
right now yeah until everything bloody
launches in october
i pray that over the next month we hear
like oh these two games are delayed
until like december i'm like excellent
fabulous
delay
um yeah i've been
we've covered most of the stuff that
i've been playing through the quarry
um
covered thoroughly overwatch too covered
thoroughly i started streaming metal
gear 3
which is a good game still very very
good
yesterday i fought the pain
and then went through to the next bit
and uh they have those flying hovering
guards remember they're like on those
like yeah they look like they're flying
on little vacuum cleaners and i was like
i'm doing a no kill run so i was like
like put one sleep i forget that when
you put them to sleep they fall to earth
and explode
and i was like [ __ ] i forgot that
happened so i like went quick to quit
the main menu it did not say after i
beat the pain so i was like oh [ __ ] say
i did not save also so it checkpointed
me just before the pain fight brilliant
but
it didn't save
and when i went back into the fight it
took away my shotgun what for some
reason that i already had at that point
when it check-pointed so it was like
today i was like give me the shotgun so
and that that fight is way more annoying
when you don't have a shotgun to get rid
of the bees um on him so i'm like trying
to throw grenades yeah his bees
that was um
two times yesterday but yeah it was good
excuse me when i die
okay
i've returned and i said you weren't
coughing at all when you were like so
passionately like uh
like going against the chorus i think
like rage like subdues it
it's it's hideo kojima the ghost of
hideo when i when i talk to you talking
[ __ ] about me it's true yeah so that was
that was a good that's a fun fight but
um yeah i
i played a bunch of mega slide three
it's it's good i'm like i think i'm like
four of the way through it now i don't
need to get back to that yeah
it's a good game the only thing i
remember is morale
that was a good fight that was fun
um yeah
so i'll probably finish playing that on
stream although i am starting to look
for like what my next new game to play
on stream is because i don't really have
anything in mind right now um
i was about to say if you tried the
quarry you literally just finished
streaming that
yep i did that in like two streams
which is like it was just it's not a
very long game
aren't they usually like six to eight
hours yeah
yeah i did like a five hour stream one
time
and that took care of most of it yeah um
and also the last two chapters in the
game are like 10 minutes like 10 minutes
and they were just movies like you don't
really interact like you just kind of
watch stuff unfold yeah um so
that's whatever but yeah i need to find
something new to play i'm just like not
excited about very much so someone
pointed out also did sakura i did sakura
in one stream basically
um completed and it was like four hours
or something like that and it just
started to finish it was the sure ending
though so yeah um
that's fine
but yeah all right let's move on to a
little game i've prepared oh no okay
it's it's it's
i'm already nervous i actually nicked
this from i can't remember who who it
was that i saw doing this i think it was
like the foot asylum
um youtube channel i saw do it um but
this game is called go it made or dead
brilliant okay
it's going to be
this is all for bands okay don't
whatever we say here don't be like ah
game developer here's what they said
about you we're just we'll just chat be
cool we'll just be cool we're just gonna
have some fun so here's how it works
okay
in this game of golden mid or dead
we have three categories goated mid or
dead
okay or three or three designations and
then i've got three categories
characters franchises and developers
okay
i'm gonna read them out one by one
and you have to put them
in either goated mid
or dead
okay
there's six per category so only two can
go in each one
okay what are each one of us doing our
own list or do we have to discuss this
discussion together okay and then and
we're gonna discuss each one together
and at the end we're gonna vote on it if
there's no clear answer okay okay all
right
which is kind of weird the one two three
[ __ ] that's not good
well you already know that my head
yeah true so it should be up three
voting for it if it's like yeah even
like yeah true true actually that makes
sense um and the idea is you can only
have two per category in each one so you
will be forced to make decisions okay
you can shift stuff around
but what do you want to case by case
basis so i don't like how much power he
has i was like he i feel like he's doing
this to make oh
thailand says audience could break a tie
audience could break that's actually
really good
so um
the categories we have are characters
franchises
and developers right okay
which one do you want to start with
characters yeah characters
characters
first character goated mid or dead
solid snake
okay
i mean
i'm not go i am not going on a record
saying that solid snake is mid if you
don't though there could be a character
that you love later on that you said
that we could move stuff around maybe
i don't know enough about his character
to really contribute to this i just know
the world from the brink of nuclear war
multiple times
so i guess then are we arguing is he a
well-written character are we arguing
like no he's just a good person like
it's all around right that's everything
everything i think you take it all into
account i mean
is it i i would personally argue solid
snake is going i mean i'll just follow
the crowd on this one because i don't
have enough of it's less is he goaded
and more what's coming up next i don't
know no you do you know the fact that if
we put this in goaded he's not going to
let us change it and it's going to [ __ ]
yes oh yeah
mid or dead
no
no you're talking to the wrong group of
people yeah
i mean we're kingdom hearts fans yeah
exactly that's why we put him in dead
yeah he's he is a isaac kingdom hearts
fan i would 100
confidently say sora is a dead character
like absolutely
sorry sorry kingdom hearts fans
like us sora yeah i will i will take
this l i'm happy to say it
we already take the l okay like which is
the close-up
oh here
which is the close-up canon which one is
that on that one that one okay
sorry is [ __ ] annoying
okay sora is one of the most annoying
video game characters ever created
and i say that as a kingdom hearts fan
that little [ __ ] is so annoying
never want to see him again
but he is coming back he is coming back
because yeah
he's dead character okay
all right
mid
or dead we've got one in goated we've
got one in dead right okay
mario mid mid really i was good yeah
yeah that's spicy i mean mario's mid
yeah what was he what was he doing i i
was actually gonna go lower
all of his supporting characters in his
games are better than mario is like
really i mean yeah yeah
you're just trying to tell me that like
mario is more interesting
wario
or you're right
so are you putting okay you are correct
but like
in terms of impact mario is pretty
you're taking everything i don't give an
issue i don't give a [ __ ] about impact i
say he's dead i put him on the character
alone you put him in dead yeah i'm
putting him in death
i think i think he's the
best right
sonic the hedgehog dead
i didn't have to [ __ ] see sonic
discourse ever again as someone who grew
up as a sega mega drive genesis kid i
was sonic all day long i will
comfortably say that character is dead
like a beyond death i feel like that is
a skeleton that keeps being reanimated i
think that about him is what makes me
love him so much i want to put him in
like i like love how much sonic is just
just a a weird corpse that sega drags
out every controls are so good and these
movies are good the archie comics were
pretty good they went on for a very long
time
there's a lot of good sonic out there
it's just
it's just his
media around the games is much better
yeah the best thing about christmas is
the best thing you have to say is roger
craig smith
and i guess julia white the
alongside mario so are we saying mid or
i'll i will i would say dead
i'll go are we gonna leave this up to
the comments to you to break the title i
said i said dead and you two said mid
i'm gonna do that he said men unless you
wanted i was gonna go go to just to be
contrary to you
i can't go that far i can't follow you
there uh do the mids have it have it
we've got two two go two um oh two deads
two dads one have it
so they're dead you're dead you're dead
or a mid
i'd probably be dead though because i
don't think it's mid sonic is because
mid to me implies bland and sonic is and
like he is either like one or he is like
the other end like they're like anything
he evens out yeah okay so currently
those games are fun disrespect to
sonic's name so sonic is currently dead
so currently we have in the gothic
categories solid snake in the mid
category mario
in the dead category sora and sonic
currently the dead category is full okay
okay yeah yeah you're gonna regret this
is oh no
link
yeah mid
link's made he is so boring though in
all of his games [ __ ] yeah mid though
yeah he's really mad he's mid he's very
mad i don't think link has ever been the
most interesting character in any one of
his games i like his character design
but that's pretty much about it he's
made
he's very mad
yeah yeah
okay that means okay so where we left
ourselves for goated we've got one
character to go into guide by default
that character is
pac-man
you should have known
you could have put sonic in mid this is
the real phone you could have sided with
me and been on the right side of history
it was too coated for you pac-man into
goated over mario
which is insane behavior
there's only one person we know who
would be happy about that
oh my god
you do have
i've given you access to two swapsies
two swaps so you could use a swap seeds
now that sounds way too close to a
certain way but once you pass this
category once we move on to the next
category let's come back to it and try
and swap c so right now but is this two
softies for the entire game or just for
this for this entire game
i would leave this alone yeah leave it
leave it leave it leave it let's save it
i want to keep our swaps
i would love to switch it so that
pac-man could be lower but i feel like
you're going to really [ __ ] us later on
this
for the record i would i would swap
pac-man out of
um
because
yes i i would
you think i want him there even miss
pac-man's better like what the [ __ ]
any of the ghosts would have been better
clyde especially yeah
that category also noticed sometimes
that category ends with in the dead
section sora from kingdom hearts sonic
from sonic yeah in the midsection
mario
and link nintendo classics in the go
it's section solid snake and [ __ ]
pacman yeah
this is wild
what have we done next is the franchise
category oh god okay let's do it gold
kid
mid
or dead
first up
call of duty
is it going is it mid or is it dead i'd
say the legacy it's had yeah
i mean like the legacy sure but i think
there's been so many of them and it's
swung so widely that i think it
comfortably lands in mid mid
that feels fair okay cool okay mid i
think that's a even with warzone
yeah like warzone's a pretty big deal
now yeah yeah but apex is better so like
it's not wrong
are you comfortable with mid then oh
yeah did you play
uh what whatever the [ __ ] that last one
was called i can remember
the last call of duty
no it was uh
vanguard
the most mid game i have ever played
yeah apologies
you know who wrote the story
to be fair i didn't play much of the
campaign just the multiplayer the
multiplayer was very mid the campaign
was all right so we're comfortable with
mid yeah okay
go it made or dead
resident evil
oh god it's got to be gorgeous
really yeah goated absolutely
but to me like
i mean there's been four
we've had like seven
is good two remakes one remake one
remake is good one remake is like one of
my favorites all the time operation
raccoon city
you've got
i'm good on you for not saying operation
raccoon shitty which is i could tell
what if we put it mid and we
maybe use one of our switcheroo things
like
later well we could just leave it and go
it then
counts leaving golden switches so you
want to put it in goat i would say yeah
because when do we get access to the
switcheroos like at the end of this
round
yeah maybe you pause let's put it in go
infinite we're putting gold yeah that
feels high that feels high for resident
evil apparently we have in mid
call of duty engulfed resident evil go
it mid or dead
final fantasy all of them [ __ ] i mean
that's also in
the same way of resident evil that is
like highs and some
i don't know i feel like is michael i am
in the chat because i'm scared for my
life
consistency considering how many games
there are
like what are the low lows of final
fantasy final fantasy vii which is
arguably like we in the last podcast you
argue one of us argued about the
devastating effect it would have the
final fantasy vii was like taken off the
board we didn't bring it up but if we
had gotten rid of resident evil 4 that
would have been not as bad i feel his
final fantasy
yeah no gears of war
i'm kind of i'm kind of with tan that i
feel like final fantasy 7 there is a
final fantasy there's been more positive
from it yeah even the negatives i like
half like resident evil you do a
spin-off and chances
yeah
yeah
you're right final fantasy spin off you
end up with tactics
you end up with crystal chronicles which
is good you get kingdom hearts i guess
um
there's a lot of like good spin on final
fantasy you get some smash characters
yeah you guys you know what
yeah cause you're right yeah so like i
feel like
i don't know would you reckon go it made
you think
alongside resident evil i feel like
we're gonna use a swap on this
okay
just trying to look at time to see if he
okay so currently we have
mid
call of duty gold resident evil go in
final fantasy there's no more room in
goid
there's only the rest of these games are
either mid
or we have another
to dead yeah what are you talking about
i'm actually okay with this because i'm
not a huge fan of grand theft auto so
like for me all right like i'll admit
we should probably swap resident evil
and grand theft auto
and oh did you watch the vice city uh
speed run on gdq oh pretty good i should
watch that the the mass effect one was
the mass effect one was hurricanes chat
says advice that is 100
there's a lot of good fight uh
grand theft auto games are probably
going threes go it
i think they're all
three basically changed open world games
i think the only one that's probably not
like amazing is
like one the very first one yeah one and
two
you know both three and five are
revolutionary and four is just good like
yeah sandra's is like
amazing invasive he's amazing yeah so
we're saying mid grand theft auto i mean
it yeah for now until we can swap it
okay
so currently we have in mid
uh call of duty whatever's left
by default the next two because of the
choices
franchises okay
halo
oh
is it a dead that's fine it's fine it's
mine
i'm sorry 343. no no
put it out at the bottom it's kind of
been it's kind of going there you're
going to say like mass effect for the
last one aren't you
or something close to our hearts i
thought he was going to do some like
soul like from software he wouldn't do
that
he would never
[Laughter]
so we're good with halo and dead yeah
yeah
okay so the final slot for
goated made or dead
has by default
gone
to mass effect oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] new dead would do this
[ __ ] wanting to put resident
evil as high as james games
mass effect is a dead franchise i
wouldn't say that
i wouldn't i wouldn't say that um
oh no but resident evil and goated i
mean to be fair the last thing if that
happened in mass effect andromeda
andromeda
which is fantastic which is a great game
well i thought i guess as well though
the last solid seven out of ten the last
thing though was the legendary edition
yeah legendary editions you know if they
hadn't announced that they're working on
five then i would actually been more
comfortable saying like
it's dead in the sense that they're
probably never gonna make it and then
we're like another one and yet
and yet but yet they are so the current
ranking is
in dead are you dead i am i'm definitely
dead i mean dead um
in dead we have mass effect and halo in
mid we have grand theft auto and call of
duty in goid we have resident evil and
final fantasy okay so here's the thing i
feel like resident evil and uh
it has to be moved down but then
yes it's do we swap resident evil with
gta or do we swap resident evil
with
a
mass effect putting mass effect and
goaded but then resident evil has to be
dead see that's the thing i want to put
i want to put resident evil down one and
i want to put uh call of duty down we
can't do that though
well no how many swaps do you say
if you want to use both of them in this
one to fix it you can
all right which one do we care about
more saving mass effect i guess
but then
we can't switch mass effect with
resident evil if that puts resident evil
at the bottom we have to
switch it i would be happy if mass
effect is made and we swap it with call
of duty yeah so you'd like oh okay i'll
take that yeah okay yeah because it
still has a lot to prove with the new
yeah you know what
i'm comfortable with that you want to
make call of duty a dead franchise yeah
yeah and mass effect a mid-franchise yes
and you're comfortable with that yeah
it's the less it's the lesser okay so
currently as it stands
the way you say are you comfortable yeah
i don't like it
it's like he's some kind of therapist
i'm like oh and how did that make you
feel just afterwards it could be
revealed that like you're gonna like um
send this to all these dudes i'm saying
this stuff yeah
is he tweeting it is informative
i'm gonna put this out with infographic
at you all in it and say like [ __ ]
chat screenshotting and it's like you
would never guess what so the final
standing for this is dead franchises
halo
and
uh call of duty mid franchises mass
effect and grand theft auto go in
franchises
final fantasy and resident evil
maybe it's a weird game time
all right final category
goed
mid
these are the developers developments
some of these are our friends dan
nintendo
got it mid or dead
can i say mid yeah i was thinking why
are you thinking
uh
because for as good as their games are i
think they have some really draconian
practices when it comes to uh
like draconian lamp uh the way they
treat like emulation and the
uh way that they like shut down fan
projects and how they just kind of like
don't even like stuff on youtube yeah
it's only stuff on youtube like i think
they are in a lot of ways a very
outdated company i would agree uh and i
think that leaves them comfortably mid
despite the high quality of their games
despite fantastic games so they're
quality the games are high quality but
they're less consistent these days yeah
i would agree with that mm-hmm like you
get pokemon does not hit nearly pokemon
anymore oh nintendo online true heart in
the chat
their entire approach to online games
yeah
mid real made and then like even like
some of their
some of the games are decidedly like
mario strikers
for example mid
i forgot that game even came around uh
swish sports sports yeah made
um sadly apart from volume apart from
volleyball there we go i just saw in the
corner of my eye just slowly what the
[ __ ] you saying
i'm willing to agree with mid okay
pulling is also good
okay voice chat via your phone
there was a period in the mid 2000s
where capcom was like [ __ ]
nose diving opinion but
i would say in the last like five or six
years they have
they have they have climbed back up
because
the top
their new games are good yes like their
remakes are good mm-hmm they're
surprisingly good at like bringing
making sure that older games are
preserved because their capcom
collections are pretty good like oh yeah
they just put out like a bunch of dark
stalkers games they're always collecting
things
their remix are obviously real good yeah
yeah so they're doing good on a bunch of
fronts but boy did they in the mid-2000s
there was so much like fumbles yeah the
way they were
yeah they've got monster hunter real
rough which is looking
like which is still a strong
they've got a few games that could be
interesting like excel primal for
example yeah is not the dyno crisis that
we all thought it was but actually
interesting they just announced dragon's
dogma so they're like giving facebook
yeah
oh they have uh mr blue says they have
the resident evil engine which is our
engine street fighter 6 is looking great
um so i don't have to make them good did
you guys know that the re engine doesn't
stand for re engine what it stands for
reach for the moon
engine yeah that's upset me yes it has
upset me
that means currently we have
in mid nintendo in goad capcom
goid mid or dead sony santa monica
oh oh god
i don't it's an interesting thing
because um they have mainly made god of
war yeah yeah and
which is a they've made good games but
they only make really like
one
series of games
yeah enough though which by the way has
been
the
the capital d discourse has been
tragic ridiculous it's been it's been
embarrassing don't understand i just
don't understand what game is yeah the
gamers are
we don't deserve anything
developers should suck stuff sony santa
monica
making the game in the god of war games
however they also work on a bunch of
other titles ranging from you know uh
uh unfinished one to like the order 1886
and
oh well
flower they've worked on they're really
olympics there's help out there just
like helping wow yeah they they're like
they've helped out with a bunch
games that princess
um
under appreciated geez
escape plan journey
[Music]
but i feel like we can't put them higher
than
mid they also helped out on a hit video
game called playstation all-star battle
royale
legend it's just so hard because like
the two that they currently going up
against like nintendo and capcom are
responsible for such a wide breadth of
successful games
which isn't like no dish to santa monica
like the games they make are pretty good
it's just it's a much narrower focus of
again i say the game is weird i mean i'm
really enjoying the game it's forcing
it's forcing some tough decision-making
but it's it's constrained by the rules
no no i'd say
but the problem is i don't want to get
be stuck in that same category where
last time where we we just and
automatically
[Music]
all i'm saying is i have created a game
that has more tension in decision making
than the quarry i feel like that's all
i'm saying i feel like i'm playing poker
and tam knows it took me 10 minutes
super massive i
said
we could we could cop out and ask chat
to vote
oh yeah that's that's chat okay chat
i'll do it we're asking chat if if
i would like to make my one call to a
friend and ask chat all right chap
what friend are you calling
like
[Laughter]
okay
paul is in the twitch chat you've got
one minute to vote where the sauna sent
sony santa monica goes and go it made or
dead
[Music]
oh oh it keeps going between like 50
between mid and goat no one has said
dead
here we go i appreciate you one person
it is currently winning that is catching
up oh my god oh my god
this is a really tough game that i
really enjoy
oh that is where mid is winning
i'm like a console watching it's like
the polls
creed says 2018 is really carrying this
dev hard yes
2018 was the last the last time i knew
peace because before that they had gator
ascension yeah attention is not as bad
as people make it out it's not as bad as
people make it out to me but it's yes
it's not great
yeah the multiplayer was completely like
it's the epitome of why do you need this
i look at ascension the way other people
look at me
that was close all right mid okay mid
that means currently in mid we have
nintendo and sony santa monica there's
no more space in mid
in
we have capcom yeah that means we've got
one spot left in goater and then two
spots left in dead
boy
goat mid or dead
arcane
goed how [ __ ] dare you
see now i feel like we've put santa
monica too high
we've put santa monica too high why'd
you [ __ ] want mid
we told you
uh we trapped ourselves again i tried to
save us i gave us all the lifeline and
you spat in my hand
swap we have activated my trap
but i saw the trap i tried to give
guidance
you know how i feel about this but i'm
not i'm not getting involved in this one
it like lucy said like arcane's just
like almost perfect games every time
yeah like except for pray except for
pray no well no according to tonight's
questions especially pray pray is great
i like pray more than i like deaf loop
same that's right yes 100 i like it more
than the first dishonest in so many ways
that were confusing to me though and i
haven't played the second dishonest
outsiders well that is a great dlc he
plays uh billy lark
extremely good mm-hmm yeah
so all kaine
will play it on the steam day are we
going for gold it does work on the steam
deck yeah it works well
lucy's lucy is pushing i put a [ __ ]
moratorium on steam deck chat until i
get mine
you've influenced me to pre-order it
prey is one of my top 10 games of all
time it has yeah arcane has to be goated
yeah yeah
yeah that means the slots and got it are
filled okay what do we get okay monica's
too high from software's gonna be in
there you know he wouldn't do it he
wouldn't no because he didn't make that
decision we made it he's putting that on
us
these are all your crimes
currently we have in goad capcom and
arcane
in mid we have nintendo
and sony santa monica that leaves two
slots
in dead
which you have decided the first of the
developers going in there is
from software
santa monica is too high
[Laughter]
so you think but the thing is if we swap
it that means we just have to say it's
mid
so now so
you put in a from software into
into dead which we still have a swap you
have a swap a single swap
what if the next one's even worse
for you okay yeah that's that's the
difficult thing then that means like if
the next one is a difficult one then you
have
you've got one swap so you can only take
one of these get for developers out of
dead
so as it stands we have
in
goad
we have capcom and arcane in mid we have
nintendo
and
sony santa monica in dead you have put
in from software leaving the final dead
slot to go to
atlas's persona team that's fine oh
the uh
what's her name for them aren't they
just called like the
team or something yeah p studio b studio
atlas's persona team that's fine in dead
that's fine the team that gave us
persona 3. that's a game that gave us a
lot of the transphobic stuff in some of
the older persona games
persona dancing wait in the older
persona games is it
persona you think are you thinking of
catherine oh no no personal four oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah no you're right it does
yeah rip are you comfortable with that
i want to save from software
so are we swapping in with santa monica
you're cool with putting persona team in
dead yeah
the creators of my favorite game of all
time persona 4
wouldn't say we were cool with it
i mean
the right choices i gave you that
lifeline with santa monica i agreed with
you i agree with you the chat the chat
made that decision i was with you chat
why you led us astray
you can now choose to move one game into
a different category okay we have to
move from we cannot live that down we
switch it with santa monica
down from software moves to mid
calls from software i feel like that's a
fake worse than being saying they're
made
so from software is now mid and santa
monica is dead
yeah
there you have it
the final challenge
i don't feel good about this sony santa
monica dead atlases persona team mid
from software
mid nintendo
go it for some reason wait we didn't put
nintendo and go it no he's going there
oh it is capcom and arcane
yeah there you have it
goid mid and dead done as a recap the
goalie characters we put
capcom nintendo and santa monica all too
high
you know it's a hard game some people
make mistakes you know you have to
everybody makes mistakes everybody makes
mistakes everybody has those teams oh
god that was the game thank you for
joining us
i'm stressed it's a stressful game it's
very very stressful game but you know
it's fun okay for who tim is this funny
for me is the chat having fun
[Laughter]
but there you go that brings another
episode of the gamespot after dark
podcast to a close do we want to do a
question do we have we've got a couple
yeah we've got a couple of pretty good
questions there's none in these
documents oh so sorry
they're in the discord there's a let me
sign the question let's do some
questions then before we wrap it up so
oh okay maria i'm sorry we missed the
steam summer sale
so your question about what game should
i buy in the steam summer sale
none none hollow night none um night
will be on sale again next year it
always is
until the game until assault song who
comes out uh tryland says what are the
three games you have the most hours
played in or think you do
well the three goated games numbers
the three games that we know or think we
have the most hours in yeah rocket
league
apex
i know for a fact those are one and two
three is
probably assassin's creed odyssey yeah
just by default yeah just because of how
still haven't finished how long it is
and the fact that like its first dlc is
like 20 hours its second one is like
30 hours and it's the last one it's like
oh here's like a 50 hour open the map on
that game and then i turned it off
i had that as a launch game for the
series x i was like no i'm right no
odyssey not valhalla not the viking one
oh the cassandra alexa oh okay okay yeah
i'm talking about valhalla is fairly
long but i think odyssey
x
that's a good one
yeah rocket league and apex are
definitely
up there for me because i think i have a
month's worth of time in apex and three
months worth of time in rocket league a
month
interesting
mine would probably be
overwatch
counter-strike
probably bloodborne yeah
checks out i think bloodborne is
probably the one i could probably chuck
in like street fighter one of the street
fighter games because i've played so
much of that [ __ ]
but i think it's probably overwatch
counter strike and bloodborne
yeah
mine would be
mass effect 2
destiny 2
probably destiny 1 but that's too sad to
both destiny games in there so i would
say the other one would probably be
persona 4
because i played that game like three or
four times damn
oh wait it's it's it's not assassin's
creed i forgot about halo reach i played
an absolute [ __ ] ton of that in
oh you know what it might be halo 3
actually
would be one of their
it could be super one of the super
smashes that i played as a kid but i
have no way to track the time of that so
it's like
yeah when the ps5 added the ability to
finally see how many hours you put into
uh like ps4 games i went and checked
destiny one and i was disgusted what was
it it was like two thousand
see the the sick sick part of me on
on xbox it lists that uh
how much time you played in comparison
to all of your friends and it even gives
you bad just like oh you're in third
place you're in second place in your
first place i'm like
[ __ ] not i'm gonna be in second or third
place i'm like i need to play this game
for like 40 more hours to be number one
out of all of my friends oh my god
so what were your ones
again oh uh it would probably it'd be
halo 3
uh destiny 2 and then probably mass
effect
mine would be
in in reverse order probably mass effect
2
then overwatch
then the sims no red dead
no i've
i
only played it once or twice right now
no i've put like
thousands of hours like and it i hate
the fact that i can say this
thousands of hours over the last 20
years into the sims yeah into the sense
you know it's like sims 2. sims takes
your life sims 2. dude and you know what
[ __ ] today they announced a high
school pack and i was like just when i
thought i was out there
so which sims have you played the most
is it two okay two is there every one
two is the best one i think a lot of
hours into one as well yeah i remember
we had everything yes we had every
expansion we just played it i remember
putting a lot into one and then just
being like i can never do this again and
so i never played two but two four and
finally the curse has never taken me
though
so good
yeah oh two has got too many expansion
packs i remember oh
i was working retail at the time and
like we had a solid like three or four
cupboards devoted just to the ikea
expansion expansion packs
because people were just buying that
[ __ ] non-stop as well no katy perry was
sims 3 right
where they added the katy perry songs
the katy perry um so she okay i hate
that she did this
she did
she did a
song in
two because that's when they all started
doing that and she had like one of the
videos it was too um but katy perry's
sweet treats was for three i think
i need to send i found uh
oh [ __ ] what's the name of that song
um
it's an eminem song
it's done
no without me no okay so
somebody recreated
in the sims 2 an m m song but the
characters were
uh
sasuke
and uh
sakura and naruto
conscious what and and and
uh
naruto was was was eminem and it was
i hate that it's so
good the first thing i have i just said
it later it's my favorite video i found
oh my god okay uh but no kate perry did
um she released hot and cold for sims 2
apartment life and then she did
apartment one and then she did last
friday night with for katy perry's sweet
treats from sims 3 yeah
that hot and cold one
oh uh the best one is um
smile by lily allen that one in the sims
is good oh and pocket full of sunshine
by natasha beninfield i know too much
anyway uh final question because i think
this is a really good one uh ben b first
i want to say i started listening to the
podcast back in february of this year
and i am only 10 episodes away from
being caught up okay first off
what dedication to actually go back and
start from the beginning you're binging
our content that's crazy 151 episodes
yeah
uh you guys gave me so many great
recommendations that my backlog filled
up even more anyways i've started a new
elden ring run with the seamless co-op
mod it's basically a complete overhaul
of the co-op in eldon ring gets rid of
all the area fog walls so you and your
friend can explore with ease
wow i would play who wants to play elden
ring with that yeah
are you gonna are you gonna
do that
i might do that with you what the co-op
mode yeah pc though
i would buy it on pc again the other
part is when someone dies the summoned
person doesn't get sent back they just
respawn in the host's world
it also gives you the ability to do
randomize it slash modded playthroughs
without getting banned from regular
multiplayer
creed says it's very easy to install
so ben's question is
have there been any mods or dlc that
you've played that have changed a major
part of the game that made it that much
more enjoyable without breaking it
entirely or to where it is almost an
entire a whole other game oh i'm the
wrong person to ask this i'm a primarily
constant guy [ __ ] mass effect
elevator mod baby
holy [ __ ]
there was a san andreas on
was it one of the can't remember which
gta mod would you take it was but there
was gta on pc
that the people
basically modded into
what it became now like what gta rp is
now yes that was san andreas san andreas
yeah so people were incredible
it was a crazy mod where people were
just like
logging in and then just
acting like their character so if your
character was a cop you had to play a
cop if your character was like a there
were people who worked like the burger
stand and there were people who were
like i am a road cleaner and i my i play
for four hours just sweeping the road
and there were other people around who
are like in for making sure that people
were actually doing their role because
they were like if if
certain people stopped doing things like
if the cops start start stopped chasing
criminals and the i don't know the
garbage men stopped picking up the
garbage the city would devolve into
madness like they had actual like
simulation stoppers like the city's full
of garbage because the garbage people
are just [ __ ] around doing missions
and [ __ ] they're not actually and i
remember being like this is
wild this is a gta mmo and now obviously
it's like that's just role-playing
everyone's doing that everyone does that
um which is amazing yeah
yeah
um i
install a lot of custom content on the
sims oh yeah yeah yeah
jordan
i
was like looking i've seen only like the
modded version of sims 4 now for so long
that i like forgot what bass sims 4
looked like and i was like
she showed it to me and i was like it is
disgusting yeah how different it looks
like it's like these these get these old
like vanilla acids out of my face they
are oh no i um i'm not annoyed but like
i had a full modded sims 4 game on my
laptop and now that i've got my pc i
cannot easily move that [ __ ] i'm gonna
have to restart everything which is fine
like i'm honestly kind of excited the
prospect also there's a big sale on sim
stuff at the moment and i hate myself
but um
no so that's that's probably like the
most the game that i have modded the
most is the sims but also like
i used to be on skyrim mods quite a lot
oh sure
and i've done
yeah
they obviously did all the modding
themselves but there's some really cool
[ __ ] on there like
new quest stuff um a lot of just like
quality of life things in skyrim in
particular like with regard to sorting
out the inventory and all that kind of
stuff um so it says i i don't think i
could play vanilla scary now i probably
would go back in and mod it
oh yeah absolutely and that way with
fallout new vegas like there are so many
mods just like simple stuff that's just
like better skylighting and better like
aim down sights and gun models and just
like there's so much you can do to
improve that that game experience so
it's hard to pinpoint like one mod yeah
um i'm super into like total conversion
mods uh where you just like completely
like make a different game so like
um
like there's the skype living people who
are like recreating all of oblivion and
skyrim they've been doing like monthly
updates and it is insane how good that
looks i mean like jake decker made like
a sorry jacob jacob yeah of course um my
bad uh he made a video um a few years
ago like talking about it um
and like i think they're just now
they're they're getting there like it's
probably actually going to come out
pretty soon and it is like
amazing how man up for a follow-up video
yeah because it's like just grabbing the
video that um it's a really good video
that one and one of my favorite cities
ever made he did a fallout one too right
i think yes yes
yes
miami and fallout frontiers something
like that there's like a colorado
expansion as well
those have not made as much progress or
at least like publicly have kind of gone
dark as you do with a mod where you
announce a mod and then you go dark for
like 10 years oh there's a dark souls
mod that's coming out oh um
something
i know it's oh i i know what it's called
i forget the name offhand it was called
nightfall yes which is that looks really
cool it picks up at the end of the game
like you start so it's like a
sequel to it you see the main character
like light the flame yeah you can see
them like the flame and kill gwyn and
light the flame and then you carry on
from there and it's got like entirely
new enemies entirely new areas got
intelligent new abilities it looks
amazing yeah it's it's a fan made sequel
to the original dark souls um
but yeah it's i'm excited to check that
out i don't think it's out yet no no i
think there's like a demo you could play
or something
there are like people streaming in i
think it's ow
oh is it okay yeah nightfall
speaking of is that
there's a stream yeah
yeah or you could do the so speaking of
uh dark souls the dark souls 3 mod where
it takes every piece of text in the game
and runs it through um translator 50
times and then back into english
um the mcelroy's played it on an episode
of monster factory and it is yes yeah as
well unbelievably good
so
if you want to make that difficult for
yourself yeah
it's very fun
yeah i think i might play nine four
interesting
okay i think that brings this episode of
gamespot after dark to a close thank you
to everyone
for tuning in if you're watching live
and you haven't already please do hit
follow on the twitch channel um
twitch.tv gamespot we will be doing more
streams we're going to be doing a bunch
of different styles of streaming as well
we've been talking about maybe doing a
lego building stream soon you know we're
just hanging out
yeah little lego together
yeah chat and stuff
um
if you are listening to this later um
maybe come over and you know hit the
like uh button on twitch but
um if you're a podcast person make sure
to subscribe and rate and review us
wherever you are
um john look what you're up to where can
people find you oh you can find me at
charlottesepp um i'm not too much but
yeah i just uh want to say thank you to
everyone who's tuned in live we do i did
add a link to like subscribe to the
podcast if you're like a first time
listener and then um yeah if you are
also a
audio only listener
um and you're in the discord or if you
want to just hit me up on twitter i'm
always looking for feedback i want to
make sure that like
the audio only experience is still a
good one you know i don't want the
live version to uh hurt that experience
so if you guys feel like there's there's
issues with that like please let us know
because i i want to take that stuff
seriously and
make sure everyone's having the best
experience with this podcast possible
yes
jordan how about you
uh you can find me on twitter at jmrmay
i have a few features that just went up
on gamespot one about uh
gothamite dev's decision making when it
came to deciding which robin that they
were going to go for
as well as a
loud plea to respawn to just not release
any new content in the next season and
please just fix the game i thank you so
much
um i i have a few like uh games that
i've been previewing
uh over the past week that i'll have
write-ups for in the coming weeks so
just be on the lookout for that oh nice
lucy
i
am on twitter at lucy james games uh
same username on twitch
uh doing a bunch of stuff on gamespot
and giantbomb in terms of gamespot stuff
it's mostly
behind the scenes really for the next
couple weeks i'm working on some
exciting projects and then over on giant
balm uh we've got jeff jeff's and we're
shooting another episode of very online
show next week i did figure out what i'm
gonna talk about which i'm very that's
like that's the worst part of the show
is trying to figure out which weird part
of the internet you want to single out
for an episode so many options there's
so much of it
um it just keeps getting weirder
it'll never end everyone just log off no
um
so yeah i'm i'm putting around and i'm
just gonna i don't know sleep for the
long weekend hope everyone enjoys in
america if you have the long weekend
please be excited to please be excited
so yeah
you know sometimes you just have to take
the day off and just not think about why
you have the day it's a holiday to
protest capitalism
that's what i'm treating it as i will
not work across these days that's what
i'm saying but will you spend money
on absolutely no no
no
i'm spending my money on chicken wings
and nothing else um i'm on twitter as
tomorrow h or some on twitch and
anywhere else that you can find me also
working on a bunch of things behind the
scenes as well as the same giant bomb
stuff
um
the important thing i wanted to mention
is
key three t-shirts oh yeah oh yeah they
are available now
you can buy the ke3 t-shirts because you
asked for it so we did it now don't do
that thing where you're like well we
don't actually want this because that
will make us look very stupid we were
like hey people actually want to buy
this so maybe we should give them the
opportunity
um you can go to store.gamespot.com
where they're available and they're like
a pre-sale capacity you can still buy
the skateboard too what the hell think
about a lot of things there yeah tam
i also included a link
to
the bootleg
ke3 t-shirt yeah don't buy that i want
you to read
the description and the one review okay
for there's a review there's a review
and it's oh my god there's no way oh
there is a room there is a review and i
want you to read that review
oh my god so the so the
the the uh
website is dm king tea and the product
listing is tomorrow saying gamespot t3
2020
sure it's available for
22.99 down from 24.99 a whole two
dollars cheaper than our version
the description is
oh my god you might not be able to read
the whole description it's a lot
the description for this t-shirt is
it also depends on if it is a climate
that require you to bring more deer snow
boots raincoats umbrellas or not my
first school was in southern california
and did not require water or weather
equipment outside of sunglasses the
second with lockers was in canada and
sometimes did require weather equipment
neither school had digital copies of
books
they both had a mix of classes that had
books you could borrow and those that
make you get the tomor hussein gamespot
key3 2022 t-shirt but in fact i love
this book
and most of my classes what is the
description what is this use electronic
copies because you're not allowed to use
your phone slash tablet slash laptop and
class that could have changed though i
did graduate like eight years ago now
what is this um it keeps going it keeps
it keeps going yeah
yeah
i just want to read this bit here but in
fact i love this ever-present concern of
theft at my first school
that's the rich
and then the first review comes from
diane
morinsky who's a verified owner of this
product it was
submitted on june 10th 2022. so even
before we even revealed the t-shirt and
we revealed it before we started selling
it but not from diane the review is
excellent great quality perfect for an
orange freak sun
many thanks
an orange what orange freak sun perfect
for my orange freak son
many thanks five stars
[Music]
i'm clicking on related i'm gonna start
saying that now perfect for my orange
for example everyone's orange freak song
wait wait no no i don't want to say that
these uh reviews are fake so i clicked
on another one
uh we've got one from atina buening fast
effective and good quality i should hope
a t-shirt is effective tina but then we
got rachel kennedy
if you want a groovy t-shirt these are
the people to use they t-h-a-y are great
i will keep coming back for more we have
to stop this podcast
i carried on reading the description for
this t-shirt and about midway through
there is this line um a bully counts on
nobody to have the courage to stand up
to them so that's what we must do for
example give a warning and tell them in
a firm voice even if you don't feel
brave i'm going to say this once knock
it off or it don't won't end well
if someone throws your stuff and tells
you to fetch grab them by the back of
the shirt and shove them hard towards
whatever they through to make sure and
make sure you yell you threw it you
fetch it
i'm sorry no lucy i'm sorry we need to
stop no no no no i'm sorry
if you go through the carousel at the
bottom it shows like related pictures
i'm sorry but i clicked on one that is a
picture of
sonic the hedgehog
pointing guns at the person and at the
top it says vampire weekend and beneath
beneath the picture of sonic it says
sonic says no to fascists and racism i
wonder
i want that t-shirt okay i want that
t-shirt too also just the final part of
this review
the final part of the description
steve harvey left a review on this sonic
shirt the final part of the description
is also be prepared for bully's parents
saying how can you accuse my sweet angel
of bullying you i see where they get it
from being busted may be enough to shame
these bullies and not bothering again
you might want to file a report with the
local police these girls will end up
either suspended expelled or in jail
where they can't bother you anymore and
nobody will see you as an easy target
after that
what a wild ride this has been
so much time anyway go buy the key
[ __ ]
store.gamespot.com to buy the official
ke3 t-shirt um it's 24
relatively cheap
and it's good quality so please enjoy
and we will see you on the next live
episode of gamespot after dark the
podcast
bye everyone bye
[Music]
[Music]
you